good morning everyone my name is jamie
crawford and i'll be giving you a brief
update
on our hemp grain and fiber trials
our trial design is a randomized
complete block where each entry is
replicated four times
plots are four feet wide and 20 feet
long and seeding rate is calculated
based on the germination rate
and seed weight of each entry so the 25
seeds are planted per square foot in the
grain and dual trials
and 40 live seeds are planted per square
foot in the fiber trials
complete hemp grain and fiber reports
for each year can be found on our
website
but this graph shows the range of grain
yields in ithaca and geneva by year
the yields for 2017 and 2019 were quite
similar
ranging from seven to eight hundred
pounds per acre
for the lower yielding entries to
thirteen hundred to fourteen hundred
pounds per acre in the higher yielding
entries
decrease in yield in 2018 was due to the
timing of harvest
one location was harvested too early
before a grain was mature
in all entries and one location was
harvested too late with much of the
grain lost to shattering our birds
when harvesting for grain timing is very
important
fiber yields in 2017 were low due to
poor seed quality and very thin stands
with new higher germinating seed lots in
2018 and 2019
entries were yielding between five and
six dry tons per acre before reading
and two and a half to three and a half
dry tons per acre after reading
we established grain and fiber trials in
two locations this spring
the first in geneva planted on june 4th
and the second
planted in ithaca on june 6th ithaca had
received six tenths of an inch more rain
than in
geneva in the two weeks leading up to
planting
and this made a huge difference in the
success of the trials
because the field was so dry when it was
prepped for planting
hard-baked chunks of soil limited seed
soil contact
had we received the predicted rain it
could have been okay but the lack of
rain in the weeks after planting led to
poor emergence and then the trial was
overrun by
wheat the additional soil moisture at
the ithaca location
led to a finer seed bed excellent
emergence and what should have been an
excellent stand if our cone cedar hadn't
been slowly breaking as we were planting
while we were planting the ithaca trials
the load bar which supported the packer
wheels was slowly twisting
planting some of the rows more deeply
and packing the soil over top of them
very
firmly we planted the fiber trial first
that day
and all six roads emerged but by the
last plot planted that day only two rows
emerged as expected
the planter was repaired and then the
grain and dual purpose trials were
replanted on june 24th
since these hemp varieties are
photoperiod sensitive
planting later leads to shorter plants
the tops of the signs in both pictures
are 30 inches from the ground
piccolo plant at the beginning of june
is close to four feet tall
piccolo planted the end of june as two
and a half feet tall
canola is over five feet tall in the
original planting and not quite four
feet tall in the replant
we expect the grain yields to be similar
between these trials
but shorter entries are more susceptible
to weed pressure
for my remaining time i'd like to show
you some pictures of our trials here in
ithaca new york
we'll start out with the fiber trial the
fiber trial was planted on june
6th so it's from the original planting
and has four entries
there are two new entries this year the
one on the left is
called yuma crossbow we had some
conflicting information
on whether it should be included in the
dual purpose or the fiber trial
and as you can see here we made the
wrong choice
it's actually earlier flowering than
some of the entries
in our dual purpose trials and we will
be harvesting it for grain
later this month
the other new entry this year is jinma
and it is a little bit later maturing
than the italian varieties we have in
the trial as sort of our checks
and it's looking really good so far
our grain trial has eight entries
starting on the left with x59
there's crs-1 in the middle
and canada on the right
in this photo that's canada again on the
left followed by uso31
in the middle and hinola on the right
and then finally this photo has piccolo
on the left
joey in the middle and cfx
2 on the right
our dual purpose trials has 15
entries this year first there on the
left you can see
nwg elite followed by nwg
abound and felina 32
in the second slide you see fedora 17
vega and then anka
this slide is futura 75 on the left
alicia in the middle and bia yoretsky
on the right
this slide contains variety we're
calling
h51 on the left ileana in the center
and rigel on the right
the final three entries in our dual
purpose trial
are altair on the left ferramon in the
middle
and voiko on the right
i'm so disappointed that we can't be
together in person to show off our
trials properly
when we've held field days in the past
i've noticed that people just cannot
help but touch and smell the plants
i can't send the smells of the hemp
field to you
but here is a video of one of our
technicians petting the hemp plots
for you to enjoy vicariously and with
that
i'll take any questions
you